i gotta ask you about two specific
moments that we see in the premiere
right the first you're in the recording
studio and you're
you know just playing around and you say
i'm getting a little tired if you
can promise his promises i'm getting a
little tired of you broken promises
promises
why was the song recorded in that
specific way
so a really long time ago ancient times
before
there was like pro tools where you could
just auto tune
on the machine there was a plug-in and
it was like in a studio it's a plug-in
box and it was called an anteris
um and this machine like all new
technology
was a little hinky and when they went to
mix my vocals
um the antares corrected the notes but
gave me a lisp
i don't i there's not there's no other
explanation for it
um if you turned the enters off i didn't
have a lisp but all my notes were wrong
so
they were like which one's better this
is your legacy i mean how
how do you feel about it i have two two
separate feelings
taking myself out of the equation
because i don't have a list
when people call me names or make fun of
it it doesn't personally affect me
because i don't have a list
however people with actual speech
impediments i don't think it's funny to
poke fun at that you know um
they do struggle with it all the time
it's not something that's funny
they're trying to communicate the same
way that you are so on that level
i'm like that's not cool like just stop
but when it's directed directly towards
me
it doesn't really hurt me because it's
not true
but i do understand and i wish people
would stop um
because they hear me talk all the time
i've done like
a lot of movies and you never hear like
it's only on that is it like do i just
get a magical lisp
on that song like i don't know you put
out some
solo music about a decade ago
what do you think of those songs and are
there plans
to release more keely williams solo
music in the future
so i don't have any plans on releasing
any solo music
at this point there is music on the show
um
i hope you guys all enjoy it um as far
as the music that i put out
when the cheetah girls was just over and
i was just it was like
you know like that gap year between like
high school and college when you're just
trying to figure it out you don't know
what you want to do
you know so that's kind of how i look at
it i don't take it too seriously
um i wouldn't sing that music i don't
think
if i were to go and be an artist today
but then i really haven't
thought about the kind of artist that i
would be
today because i'm not the same person i
was 10 years ago you know
i've got a baby and a husband
and you know lots of different
responsibilities and
a different set of experiences that i
would want to share you don't want to be
in a group
you're obviously not creative director
so what are you a starter
you've kind of been living behind the
camera for the last decade or so
what was it about this project that you
were like i'm ready to come out of
retirement and let's do this
the original attraction to the project
was how much i
hate the stigma that girl groups can't
stay together
and even though i'm pretty negative
about the probability of girl group
staying together
i still have this like if i can only
find the right formula if i can only
just figure out
like the right personality types the
right circumstance like
what could make it work because women
can work together in every other
industry in the world it just seems like
girl groups it's like something always
happens and there's drama
and infighting and all that stuff and i
just wanted to dispel that myth
because i don't believe it's true i i
really do think that if women come
together
working towards a common goal we can do
absolutely anything